phoenix runde
schönen guten abend ganz herzlich
willkommen aus berlin ich darf meine
gäste vorstellen julia klöckner ist bei
uns von der cdu sie kennen als
ministerin für landwirtschaft und
ernährung hat jetzt eine neue rolle sie
ist die wirtschaftspolitische sprecherin
der cdu/csu-fraktion im wunderland hallo
und der wirtschaftspolitische sprecher
der grünen das ist dieter janitschek
erst 2013 im bundestag seine heimat ist
bayern dort war auch noch vorsitzender
der grünen und ich begrüße hermann josef
tenhagen er ist er 2014 chefredakteur
des gemeinnützigen verbraucher ratgebers
finanztipps und herzlich herzlich
willkommen christian geinitz
wirtschaftskorrespondentin der
parlamentsredaktion der faz in berlin
mit dem schwerpunkt klima energie und
gesundheit wir reden gleich über all
diese pläne aber heute stellt die ampel
ja in der bund in der woche in dieser
ganzen woche im bundestag ihre pläne vor
und am vormittag der präsentierte robert
habeck erstmal seine ideen wir stehen
also wenn wir es richtig angehen vor
einer großen phase des industriellen und
das ist dann ein mittelstands durch die
zulieferindustrie und ein handwerks
aufschwung in deutschland ja man kann
darüber klagen die schwer alles ist und
wie groß die herausforderungen sind und
wie sehr wir in rückenlage anfangen ich
will das nicht mehr tun ich sehe die
chancen für die deutsche wirtschaft ich
sehe die chance für wachstum und
klimaschutz das sich wunderbar ergänzen
kann
wachstum und klimaschutz wirtschaft
klimaschutz das soll sich alles
ergänzung für glockner wir haben sie ja
da eben schon gesehen sie haben ja dann
reagiert heute auf die rede des
ministers die chance für die deutsche
wirtschaft das ist dieser umbau sagt
robert habeck sehen sie es auch so das
kann eine chance sein aber ich warne
auch davor sich das alles schön zu reden
denn wir müssen uns einfach mal
anschauen in welcher lage die deutsche
wirtschaft aktuell ist sie hat im
zweiten jahr die korona pandemie
zustimmen teile in unserer wirtschaft
leiden massiv darunter dann kommen noch
erhöhte strom energiepreise dazu
lohnnebenkosten die steigen schauen wir
uns an lieferketten unterbrochen sind
auch wenn die auftragsbücher voll sind
es kann geliefert werden und dann
fachkräftemangel also wenn wir uns das
alles anschauen dann ist es schön also
der minister hat vom turbo für den
klimaschutz gesprochen wir brauchen aber
auch ein turbo für die wirtschaft er hat
sich jetzt in jüngster zeit mehr als
klimaschutzminister geäußert aber wir
erwarten auch dass er auch sein amt als
wirtschaftsminister auch war nicht da
sehen sie dann sozusagen auch immer zwei
pole oder sind in mettmann versöhnen
kann und soll ein die muss man natürlich
versuchen also wirtschaft kommt
leidet selber darunter wenn die
klimatischen wandel und auch die die die
implizierten kosten da haben natürlich
hat wirtschaft ein hohes interesse an
einer energieversorgung die verlässlich
ist keine frage aber umgekehrt müssen
wir auch immer schauen dass wir
wettbewerbsfähig bleiben dass wir
realistische ziele haben dass wir über
die instrumente reden also die ziele die
in der ferne liegen da kann man sich
auch schnell einig sein aber wenn es uns
hier und jetzt geht dann wird es konkret
und darum und darüber müssen wir
streiten wir dann vielleicht auch genau
herr janáceks wie sehen sie ist dann der
muss denn dann diesem aufschwung leisten
von dem robert habeck spricht erst mal
ist das ambitioniert was wir hier
vorhaben dass wir bis 2030 auf 80
prozent der erneuerbaren energien bei
einem steigenden strombedarf kommen das
ist wirklich ambitioniert und ich würde
sagen wenn wir das schaffen dann können
wir sehr zufrieden sein und das ist in
der tat richtig das ist das auch ein
steiniger weg werden wird dass wir auch
konflikte haben werden es geht um den
leitungsausbau es geht um die frage ob
menschen vor ort windräder haben wollen
es geht auch um die frage dass wir die
systemintegration leisten wollen die
speichertechnologien und auch übrigens
gaskraftwerke in einem gewissen umfang
die wir dazu brauchen werden das alles
zusammen zu denken das ist erst mal der
steinige weg aber die chance ist ja dass
wir unsere industrie modernisieren mit
wasserstoff strukturen mit
kreislaufwirtschaft dass wir die
menschen mitnehmen vor ort dass wir
einfach einen klima wirtschaftlichen weg
gehen die unsere wettbewerbsfähigkeit
stärken und meine persönliche ansicht
ist dass klimaschutz und wirtschaft in
der heutigen zeit unmittelbar zusammen
gehören vielleicht noch ein
zahlenbeispiel wir haben dieses jahr
letztes jahr war es für 30 milliarden
euro ja bei der hochwasserkatastrophe im
art teilen oder westfalen und rheinland
pfalz auf den weg gebracht als
hilfspaket das ist ein schreckliches
ereignis gewesen ich würde gerne dass
wir die investitionen in bereiche
schieben die in der zukunft solche
ereignisse weniger möglich machen also
ich glaube wir müssen uns einfach auch
von der längeren 16 aber natürlich frau
klöckner hat insofern recht wir müssen
auch kurzfristig die
wettbewerbsfähigkeit der wirtschaft
ungarn ist wie würden sie es denn
beurteilen hat ist diese botschaft bei
der wirtschaft angekommen darf halt eben
wirtschaft klimaschutz energiewende das
ist alles zusammengehört
diese botschaft ist durchaus angekommen
und die wirtschaft ist ja auch bereit
gerade heute der bundesverband der
deutschen industrie bdi noch einmal
erklärt dass er die hand ausstrecke dass
die ziele im grunde die gleichen seien
nur für die wirtschaft ist ja
entscheidend und genauso für die
privathaushalte dass dieser umbau
finanzierbar bleibt und er muss warum
der präsident des bda triton erinnert
dass herr scholz der neue kanzler
seinerzeit versprochen hat eine
industrie preis von 4 cent pro
kilowattstunde und damit könnte die
industrie gut leben tatsächlich liege
jetzt aber deutlich drüber ich glaube
bei 26 cent und solange das so ist wird
das natürlich eine herkulesaufgabe
insbesondere auch für die industrie
damit sie ihre wettbewerbsfähigkeit da
nicht verliert und das ist entscheidend
für ein industrieland natürlich für
deutschland das ja keine oder zu wenig
eigene ressourcen hat und deswegen war
auch nicht zuletzt von seinem export
lebt unter wettbewerbsfähig bleiben muss
wir sind eben nicht alleine in diesem
winter auf dieser welt und an diesem
europa und jetzt fragen sich ja ganz
viele verbraucher tenhagen viele
verbraucher sehen schockiert auf die
benzinpreise sehen schockiert auf die
gaspreise oder haben früher zum
günstigen stromanbieter gewechselt
merken auf einmal das funktioniert so
nicht mehr also kämpfen sowieso schon
mit hohen energiepreisen und wenn sie
jetzt diese klimapläne höheren
befürchten natürlich alle gott wie teuer
werden denn die energiekosten noch was
können sie denn zu deren berufung sagen
da kann man erstmal zwei dinge sagen
also erstens alles das was wir heute an
hohen energiepreisen haben ist ja nicht
ergebnis der politik dieser neuen
regierung sondern wenn ergebnis der
politik der alten regierung und dann
muss man auch tatsächlich mal schauen
was da an an regulierung auch für
verbraucher möglich ist es hat gerade
von den vier cent für die industrie
gesprochen in pforzheim nimmt das
stadtwerk von neukunden 107 cent
pro kilowattstunde in soest oder in
gütersloh oder ich glaube auch in der
nähe von köln mit 80 90 cent pro
kilowattstunde von neukunden beim strom
aufgerufen und das muss geändert und das
ist uns auch viel viel mehr als jede
regierung sich vorgestellt hatte selbst
mit allen möglichen co2 abgaben die dame
auf dem weg sind also da muss was
passieren damit die leute das gefühl
haben das geht in die richtige richtung
wieder für sie und dann wird es dann
auch von den arbeitsplätzen her sehe ich
das genau wie die drei vorrednern das
gesagt haben da sind jede menge chancen
also klempner die solaranlagen aufs dach
bauen wollen die haben eine goldene
zukunft elektriker die photovoltaik
anlagen bauen sollen und wollen haben
eine goldene zukunft und unsere
industrie dann am ende gesagt also wir
sollten wir sind ja exportweltmeister
vize-weltmeister nach den chinesen aber
da müssen wir die technologien liefern
für für alle anderen auch ideen braucht
den umbruch in der klimapolitik hier
auch machen müssen aber eigentlich
dieses klimaziel ich hab es am anfang
gesagt dieses bis 2045 klimaneutral zu
sein ist ja ein ziel der alten regierung
frau warum sind wir da jetzt eigentlich
nicht weiter das ist ja das was robert
habeck kritisiert dass er sagt da ist so
wenig vorarbeit geleistet aber er hätte
ja wenn er meint er kann es besser hätte
ja ein anderes ziel definieren können
und wenn man sich mit der materie
beschäftigt auch mit der umsetzung
beschäftigt also jetzt nicht nur was
schönes in den himmel malt wie es
aussehen soll sondern vom hier und jetzt
beginnt und wir haben ja im übrigen wenn
wir uns anschauen co2
reduktionsziele haben wir 220 auch
erreicht gehabt also es war ja eine
kanzlerin angela merkel unter der das
auch alles begonnen hatte auch damals
als umweltministerin und man kann sagen
man ist zu spät gestartet ende der 90er
hätten viel früher starten können das
ist zurückblicken wenn wir jetzt heute
uns das anschauen wenn wenn ich erinnere
mich noch wie wir das klimaschutzgesetz
im kabinett verabschiedet hatten noch in
der alten bundesregierung wie wir darum
gerungen hatten ich für den bereich der
landwirtschaft auf was ja da und co2
einsparen dann im boden binden etc bei
all diesen fragen haben wir so gerungen
wie das zu überprüfen ist denn die frage
ist ja am ende welche schritte geht man
realistisch und wie kann man nach
steuern und bei diesem klimaschutzgesetz
weiß ich noch was den grünen nicht
ambitioniert genug und der fdp war es zu
unrealistisch und ging zu weit und
schauen wir uns jetzt die ziele an die
ziele sind die gleichen
also hat man wohl erkannt auch in der
neuen regierung das wünschen natürlich
auch unterlegt werden müssen mit
überprüfbaren und realistischen schritt
ja und die frage ist wie viel man den
bürgerinnen und bürgern zumuten kann das
kommt hinzu her was ist das kriterium
dafür her ja in check hat ja diese
grafik gezeigt am montag in der
bundespressekonferenz wo man klar
gesehen hat wie es stärkt das steigen
muss der anteil der erneuerbaren
energien und dann wird's wenn es konkret
wird schwierig nämlich bei der frage zum
beispiel des windrads aufbau als wir was
kann man leben
das signal ist schon dass wir auch
zumuten wollen natürlich auch im dialog
obertal berg fährt er jetzt auch in alle
bundesländer auch in meinem bundesland
nach bayern spricht mit herrn söder ob
es sinnvoll ist die abstandsregel für
die windkraft aufrecht zu erhalten das
wird übrigens die bayerische wirtschaft
selber nicht die hat dagegen protestiert
auch im wahlkampf schon aber in der tat
rollen die möchte nicht diese
abstandsregelung weil die wirtschaft ja
längst verstanden hat dass sie nur
wettbewerbsfähig sein kann wenn wir raue
mengen zusätzlichen erneuerbaren strom
produzieren der deutlich günstiger ist
als fossile strom die preis problematik
die wir heute haben die hätten wir gar
nicht wenn wir in den letzten jahren
schon deutlich ambitionierter zu gebaut
haben und deswegen glaube ich ist das
signal schon wir wissen dass da härten
kommen wir wissen dass auch der
netzausbau ich kenne das auch aus bayern
das ist kein spaß gewesen für den
netzausbau in regionen einzustehen wo
die menschen das gefühl hatten sie
werden da auch übergangen das gilt
übrigens auch für kapazitäten von
gaskraftwerken die wir als ergänzung
brauchen werden und das thema
windenergie im gegensatz zur
photovoltaik die ist leichter
durchsetzbar wenn sie heute ein
gewerbebetrieb sind und dann haben sie
jetzt die pflicht oben die photovoltaik
drauf zu tun kriegen eine gute förderung
dann machen sie das ja auch weil sie
dann davon auch profitieren und das
klima profitiert also es muss eine
erfolgsgeschichte werden aber sie wird
auch mit zumutungen verbunden so haben
wir ja wir müssen auch aber vorher uns
klar sein bei den zielkonflikten schauen
wir uns die umweltministerkonferenz ich
glaub 11 grüne minister sind dateien
da geht es nicht in eine richtung obwohl
sie alle grüne minister sind und wir
sehen es gibt zielkonflikte zwischen
umweltschutz zwischen tierschutz
vogelschutz aber auch die frage der
erneuerbaren energien sie wissen wir
haben schwer gekämpft und kämpfen um
unseren wald weil der arg gelitten hat
und wenn jetzt gesunde wälder oder teile
von gesunden wäldern gerodet werden für
für windräder dass das vor ort auch zu
unverständnis für das muss man verstehen
und wenn wir sagen raue mengen zum
beispiel auch von windrädern wir müssen
achtgeben dass wir hier aus berlin nicht
über ländliche räume entscheiden das
heißt es die ländlichen räume nachher
die kompensations orte für für
städtische wünsche dann aber dass die
ländlichen räume gerade profitieren
können wenn wir ihnen die wertschöpfung
vor ort ermöglichen und natürlich ist es
beim ausbau der windenergie so jetzt
schaut man sich zum beispiel die
konversionsflächen der bundeswehr an man
guckt sich auf offshore an was man dort
zu bauen kann also man schaut das schon
genau hin aber die wahrheit ist am ende
dann doch so dass wir deutlich mehr
windenergie brauchen und das holz
leitung ungleichheit und 1 2% flächen
ziel heißt wirklich dass wir auch
eingriffe in der landschaft haben werden
und das kann man nur lösen indem man die
menschen vor ort beteiligt wie es hier
mit der bürgerenergie damals vor 20
jahren als das
wollen wir natürlich auch das heißt wir
reden in der tat intensiv auch mit den
umweltverbänden und sind auch auf einer
linie dass wir den ausbau der
erneuerbaren wollen und den artenschutz
und der lässt sich in aller regel bis
auf wenige ausnahmen auch vereinbaren
sterben
ja auf dem land ist es aber doch gar
nicht so schwierig also ich gut ich
komme vom bauernhof also ich kann ihnen
sagen bei meinem bruder seine
kolleginnen und kollegen die haben alle
eine solaranlage auch im kuhstall gebaut
bevor sie den nächsten treffer die
solaranlage
problem moment mal das windrad auf ihrem
acker ried anlagen wie man es als die
beste vorfall glaube das ist eine menge
an möglichkeiten ist wenn man den leuten
das tatsächlich schmackhaft also ich
verstehe ja gar nicht warum zum beispiel
diesen bauern keinen strom für e autos
so sagen absetzen dürfen warum dann
nicht der der mensch aus dem dorf
sozusagen sich beim bauern an den an die
solaranlage dranhängen kann und dort
sein auto aufladen kann warum das noch
nicht verstehen ich kann der rh werks
darum kümmern aber solche fragen sind
doch man kann doch wenn in den
situationen jede menge produzieren und
für die für die leute ist das wichtig
dass wir diese win win situation
begreifen aber dafür sich sehen was sie
machen können was sie selber machen
können ja dann kann machen was ich
erwarte also wir mit dem regime erheben
das wäre nicht in bullerbü her jetzt
kommen und dann plötzlich von der
realität erschrocken sind bleiben wir
beim landwirt der hat auf seinem acker
windrad stehen das ist die beste
fruchtfolge das rechnet sich super nur
wenn wenn das aber sein acker ist und
seine einnahme ist was meinen sie wie
sein nachbar freut er das windrad zieht
aber diese einnahmen nicht hat und noch
mal wir sind da hier beieinander aber
wir müssen glaube ich auch sehr klar
sein es gibt vielmehr zielkonflikte als
die die wir jetzt angesprochen haben wir
sprechen auch von flächenversiegelung
wir sprechen ja es wird
flächenversiegelung sein wer sich ein
windrad anschaut wie massiv das muss ja
auch auch und manifest sein wir werden
hier wirklich deshalb sage ich realismus
wenn wir die leute mitnehmen wollen dann
dann wird es auch zeit brauchen ich bin
für planungs beschleunigung und der
ausbau beschleunigung absolut aber im
übrigen nicht nur bei der nada muss man
reinen wein einschenken und deshalb die
frage wir haben eben dieser moment sagt
der langjährige nebenleute soll so eine
ist so eine win win situation da würde
ich gerne ganz nah man nachfragen bei
robert habeck klingt das ja auch so ein
bisschen so als gäbe es irgendwie nur
gewinner wer verliert den ball so einer
transformation oder gibt es auch gibt es
wirklich nur gewinner
na das wird nicht nur gewinner geben und
der minister sagt ja auch und hat immer
gesagt und janácek hat dass er ihm
wiederholt es gibt auch zumutungen und
ich glaube ihm dieser ganzen debatte
müssen wir uns klar werden das wird
nicht sozusagen ohne preise zu gekommen
sein es wird zumutung geben es wird
verzicht geben müssen er muss sich noch
nicht vergessen wenn wir über preise
reden und naja zu verzichten müssen
müssen zum beispiel diejenigen die ab
verbrennungsmotor autos fahren wollen
oder die energie noch ne oder eine
gasheizung haben es gibt ja berechnungen
was das an kosten verursacht wenn man
hier zu sagen bei den alten
energieträgern verharrt und das ist ja
auch gewollt diese alten energieträger
sollen teurer gemacht werden damit sich
die neuen durchsetzen und für mich ist
ganz entscheidend tatsächlich das kann
man ja vielleicht im nationalen
durchhalten und die frage ist
tatsächlich die internationale
wettbewerbsfähigkeit zu machen wenn oder
zu gewährleisten wenn diese zumutung
sich dann in heller und pfennig in den
betrieben niederschlagen und zu den
zielkonflikten planung einsatz das
vielversprechende ja jetzt ist dass
diese zielkonflikte innerhalb des wird
dazu sagen darf des grünen lagers liegen
dann hat mich so ein bisschen an die
agenda 2010 von gerhard schröder damals
diese
verschärftes fördern und fordern am
arbeitsmarkt wo die cdu immer gesagt die
union gesagt hat im nachhinein wir waren
ja ganz glücklich dass die dass die die
spd und die gewerkschaft mit den
gewerkschaften das durchsetzen wir
hätten das nicht hinbekommen und ähnlich
verhält es sich jetzt auch mit den
grünen die ja dann tatsächlich mit ihren
eigenen interessen gruppen den
artenschutz an den naturschützern dem
tierschützern sich auseinandersetzen
müssen möglicherweise wenn das so
integrativ passiert wird der minister
das vorschlägt möglicherweise dann auch
tatsächlich zu lösungen kommen denn in
der tat kann man ja die kommunen
beteiligen an den eigenen namen übrigens
keine neue idee der neuen regierung
sondern sollte die alte auch schon viele
dieser dinge die jetzt als neu verkauft
wurden werden sind ja nur alte konzepte
auch er altmaier wollte den strom in den
kommunen verbilligt an die kommunen
weitergegeben oder sie an den gewinnen
beteiligen so ganz neu ist das alles
nicht mal wenn man ehrlich ist dreimal
bei diesen grünen zielkonflikten herr
janácek tatsächlich gibt es ja lob von
der industrie haben wir eben gehört
haben und der deutschen industrie was ja
dass er das eigentlich gut findet und
dann gibt es aber ziemlich viel ärger
von freies für future die sagen das geht
uns alles gar nicht weit genug also in
wie weit sind sie da eigentlich einig
und stehen als partei- und auch als
fraktion hinter den plänen von kanal es
ist absolut richtig dass freiheit ist
für future noch mehr tempo will und das
soll auch so sein und wir versuchen
jetzt das möglich zu machen in der
regierung was möglich zu machen ist und
wir werden diese zielkonflikte angehen
das heißt artenschutz und übrigens auch
landwirtschaftliche interessen kann man
vereinbaren zb mit der freiflächen
photovoltaik wo sie dann die böden
benutzen können wenn sie ein windrad
aufgebaut haben und dass irgendwann mal
nicht mehr brauchen bei uns ist wieder
ab es gibt natürlich einen teil der
versiegelung aber wir können auch die
senken die wälder stärken also wir
müssen das als ganzheitliche politik
sehen dann steht übrigens auch ein
halbwegs klimakonzept drin da geht es
nicht nur um industrie da geht es zum
beispiel auch um die frage wie wir die
wälder stärken also all das muss man
glaube ich ganzheitlich entwickeln mit
den menschen vor ort und da wir in einem
zeitalter leben wo auch schnell protest
organisiert ist und auch wir grüne
kennen das wir haben das auch oft
genutzt werden wir natürlich jetzt
insofern auch zurecht uns damit
auseinandersetzen müssen dass der
protest auch gegen unsere eigenen
maßnahmen zum teil kommen wird ich habe
da trotzdem keine angst
ich glaube dass
ich glaube dass es gar nicht so sehr
dieser konflikt sei also zum beispiel
der trassen ausbau in bayern der wurde
nicht von den grünen bekämpft das wurde
zwar oft gesagt er wurde von herrn
seehofer damals bekämpft und von den
freien wählern von der bank jetzt ich
habe mich damals hingestellt und den
krassen ausbau in bayern kritisiert und
gesagt das brauchen wir also die
ziellinie sind ja heute völlig anderer
geworden dass sie immer menschen haben
die vor ort angst haben die angst muss
man ernst nehmen dass sie beeinträchtigt
werden zum beispiel durch ein windrad
oder dass sie nicht beteiligt werden
oder dass infrastrukturplanung kommt wir
reden übrigens auch vom ausbau der bahn
die wir brauchen werden von
ladeinfrastruktur
also wir reden von einem gigantischen
infrastrukturen industrieprojekt und das
heißt wir werden definitiv auch
konflikte haben aber wir haben ein
tolles projekt wo alle mitmachen können
das ist auch darum könnte man noch mehr
menschen überzeugen wenn man wüsste dass
zb strom billiger würde herr tenhagen
wenn wir jetzt das alles durchsetzen
diese pläne dann fragen sich natürlich
die bürger okay wenn ich meinen
solarpanel auf dem dach habe habe wird
wahrscheinlich ein bisschen billiger
oder wer muss das wer hilft mir das zu
bauen all diese dinge also könnten sie
da eine beruhigende antwort geben für
die bürgerinnen und bürger
naja wenn sie ein eigenes dach zur
verfügung haben ist das super sie können
heute auf dem eigenen dach den strom
führt zu 12 14 cent ab beugen die
herausforderung ist wie erzeugen den
strom wenn mittags die sonne scheint und
sie wollen den abends nutzen das heißt
sie brauchen auch nur eine batterie also
nach denen sie irgend einer garage
stehen haben um besser nutzen zu können
dann können sie aber heute 60 bis 70
prozent dieses stroms nutzen und der ist
eben für 15 cent zu haben oder unter 15
10 und nicht das was stadtwerke heute
aufrufen 30 cent oder große
stromkonzerne und schon gar nicht das
was jetzt
krisen profiteure aufrufen wenn der
stromanbieter tatsächlich
neukunden die herausgeworfen sind worden
worden sind woanders strom für 80 cent
oder für 1 euro pro kilowattstunde an
wie das sind krisen profiteure und das
schlimme dabei ist das eine oder andere
davon ist ein stadtwerk und das hat den
aufsichtsratsvorsitzenden und des
oberbürgermeister von der cdu in
pforzheim oder oberbürgermeister von der
spd in büren die müssten sich mal darum
kümmern was ist ihre stadtwerke ihren
bürgern gerade zu tun die machen den
gerade angst wenn sie dem bürger sagen
würden diese in der solaranlage aufs
dach bauen können und wie sie mit der
solaranlage für 15 cent den strom
erzeugen dann wäre das super da gibt es
förderprogramme für auch schon von der
alten regierung kann man für eine neue
von der neuen regierung sicher
fortsetzen weitermachen da gibt es also
die leute machen dass die können heute
wenn sie die heizung rauswerfen
ölheizung rauswerfen eine neue einbauen
können sie 45 prozent förderung von
vater staat bekommen dann müssen sie zur
zeit nur noch den klempner finden der
das mit ihnen machen
und sie haben hätten sie haben immer
dafür geworben dass man wechselt viele
leute sind gewechselt zubilligen
stromanbieter und haben jetzt das
nachsehen also das ist doch dann auch
schwierig war schon da kann ich ganz
kann ich ganz deutlich sagen vor denen
wo die hinten die da jetzt zu gemacht
haben haben wir immer schon gewarnt weil
das haben wir vor jahren schon sehen
dass die unter kosten kalkulieren und
dass die leute hinter die fichte führen
wir haben das extra also meine finanzen
haben das extra so gemacht dass wir vor
denen schon gewarnt haben und daher
nicht das haben wir da nicht das problem
aber natürlich ist das so wenn jetzt
leute rausgeworfen wenn das nützt den ja
nichts dass wir damals gewarnt haben sie
müssen jetzt eine lösung haben und die
brauchen jetzt eine lösung wo sie zu
einem vernünftigen annehmbaren preis wir
sind strom kaufen können das sind dann
35 cent vielleicht aber doch nicht 80
oder 90 oder 1 euro 7 in von er und wir
sind aber wenn man im vergleich mit
anderen ländern frau klöckner hat
deutschland eben extrem hohen preise was
natürlich auch für mittelstand und
kleinere unternehmen extrem schwierig
ist wenn wir jetzt getan was brauchen
die bürgerinnen und bürger die brauchen
der förderung all das was braucht in der
mittelstand genau um dieses ziel hin zu
kriegen
wir müssen achtgeben mittlerweile haben
wir auch so förderdschungel dass man
dann noch durchblickt ist auch nicht
immer ganz einfach die ganz großen
wissen dass kleinere unternehmen eine
gießerei etc die kommen dazu selten ja
dass sie wirklich schauen welche neuen
fördertopf gibt es jetzt auch wieder
muss man wirklich sagen und im zweifel
ist das ein ganz leise sterben was wir
gar nicht mitkriegen gerade die kleinen
wir haben ja den über über überwiegenden
teil in deutschland sind die kmu also
sind ja dann die reise in den orient
tschuldigung genau kleinere und mittlere
unternehmen sind er ist ja gar nicht die
große industrie die auf gute lobbyarbeit
machen kann sondern es geht mir wirklich
auch um diesen mittelstand und das sind
verschiedene stellschrauben worum es
geht zum beispiel das thema eeg umlage
oder die eeg-kosten jetzt 2023 haben sie
jetzt es war im koalitionsvertrag noch
nicht konkretisiert da gab es wohl noch
keine einigung jetzt haben sie 2020
genannt ich meine da mirabeau liegen
genau dass die abgaben
also es geht um die abschaffung und der
der umlage und 2023 also wenn sie den
turbo an warfen dann könnte man schon
früher damit beginnen gehen wir weiter
es sind ja andere belastung die die
unternehmen ja auch noch haben gerade
der mittelstand im übrigen was
kostentreibend ist ist auch die
bürokratie ist auch die die belastung
200 mal hörte ich heute hat ein
durchschnittliches unternehmen kontakt
mit behörden und das ist so aufwendig
was ich nicht verstehe ist es das
kabinett gestern beschlossen hat das was
vorher chefsache war bürokratie
entlastung der normenkontrollrat dass
dieser kontrollrat jetzt abgezogen wird
aus dem kanzleramt und das unter ferner
liefen ins justizministerium bahn hat
das ist ein punkt aber es sind ganz ganz
viele weitere punkte die wir haben wo
ich persönlich eine dass wir wenn es um
steuer um liquidität geht wenn es darum
geht auch um sozialabgaben geht wenn es
darum geht wie können wir es jetzt mal
ein turbo für die wirtschaft auflegen
dann brauchen wir wirklich passende
programm und dazu habe ich vom
wirtschaftsminister heute gar nichts
gehört also zu wenig wirtschaft zu viel
klimaschutz oder oder sagen wir so viel
aber nicht nur wieder brannten passen
was hilft mir der klimaschutz wenn ich
nachher die unternehmen ja nicht habe
und es überhaupt kein exportschlager ist
wie wir unsere klima wände oder unseren
energiewende angehen also zu glauben wie
wir verhinderten hat nh genannte ja wir
müssen ja auch produzieren für den
ganzen export weil die alle uns das dann
auch nachmachen also es sieht jetzt noch
nicht so sehr danach aus dass alle sagen
das ist super wie deutschland das hier
gerade macht wir müssen schon noch
zeigen so dass unsere ziele haben wir
uns ein
riesenerfolg also warum tesla der
riesenkonzern geworden ist und wo die
deutschen autobauer zwischen 2010 und
2018 eigentlich gewesen sind und ob es
vielleicht sein kann dass wir die e
autos in deutschland vor allem deswegen
haben wir die chinesen gesagt haben wenn
ihr nicht mehr autos bei uns produziert
dann fliegt der ball bei uns raus also
da haben wie soll ich sagen ich herr
winterkorn hatte andere prioritäten als
die autos nicht darauf eingehen es ist
natürlich in der tat so dass wir bei
technologiethemen will es auch nicht
immer vorne waren in den letzten jahren
in deutschland gerade was das automobile
thema angeht kann ich mich um leidigen
debatten im deutschen bundestag die
übrigens glaube ich heute beendet wurden
weil herr wissing erklärt hat dass mit
dem if you ist das vielleicht doch nicht
die beste idee um die automobilindustrie
fit zu machen also dass dieser
technologie trend da war ist lange
verschlafen worden auch von der politik
auch verleugnet worden und der ist
einfach unausweichlich wenn sie heute
mit dem chef von audi oder von vw oder
auch von daimler reden dann sagen die
alle die bauen das jetzt und die machen
das jetzt und ich hoffe sehr dass die
deutsche automobilindustrie jetzt auch
auf holt das ist nämlich sonst ein
problem für unseren standort wenn sie
nicht auf holt und dass die
investitionen kommen ich wollte aber
noch was sagen zu dem ganzen kümmerer
themen ich habe diesen sommer die ganze
baustoffindustrie besucht vom kiesel bis
zum zementwerk bis zu der frage wie wir
künftig wie sie unternehmen wie knauf
dann beispielsweise wo dann beim koks
also die kohle dann ausgeht sozusagen
das sind natürlich themen also mit der
energiewende kommen ganz viele seiten
themen die wir bearbeiten müssen und
alle unternehmen haben heute einen
dekarbonisierung skat alle alle branchen
das ist ja fantastisch für politik aber
das heißt natürlich in der tat dass sie
jedes mal die branchenspezifische
schauen müssen was brauchen die
eigentlich am ende als partnerschaft von
der politik 1 planungs beschleunigung
auch die verlässlichkeit planbarkeit und
eben auch die aussage in der zukunft
wird investiert in den erneuerbaren
bereitschaft der anderen soll alles ganz
schnell gehen herr gerne zu was würden
sie denn sagen was braucht der
mittelstand von der politik ist das also
außer vielleicht fördermitteln ist und
ist diese frage nach dem tempo weil das
ist ja das was er was bei herr becker so
klar wurde dass er das unheimlich
beschleunigen will überfordert man damit
um gerade den mittelstand zum beispiel
oder kleinere unternehmen
der mittelstand braucht
planungssicherheit
anders als die großindustrie zahlt daher
immer noch die eeg-umlage
die großen unternehmen sind weitgehend
befreit die soll jetzt war abgelöst
abgeschmolzen im nächsten jahr soll sie
wegfallen
andererseits sagen vergleichsportale wie
verivox
dass das keine so riesen rolle spielt
und wenn man sich mal anschaut jetzige
vermeintlich so kleine eeg umlage wird
2012 glaube ich schon mal niedriger als
sie jetzt ist und wenn wir nur einen
satz sagen da frau klöckner mit verlaub
die abschaffung schon im vorzuziehen wie
sieht das heute im bundestag verlangt
haben das hätten sie ja zu ihrer zeit
auch machen können oder die csu die
stromsteuer senden das ist nicht erfolgt
deswegen ist es ein bisschen wohlfeil
jetzt der neuen regierung zu sagen jetzt
zieht das bei vor und entlastet die
leute die linke hat heute einen ganz
interessanten vorschlag gemacht die
mehrwertsteuer auf die auf die
energieträger entsprechend zu senken das
wären aber alles ja er sofort maßnahmen
die eigentlich langfristig an der
strompreisentwicklung oder in der
energiepreisentwicklung muss man ein
richtiger sei weil sie sagen nichts
ändern werden also der mittelstand
braucht verlässliche rahmenbedingungen
damit planen kann er braucht natürlich
auch schnellere genehmigung aber er muss
vor allem bei den kosten
wettbewerbsfähig
bleiben und da weiß ich so ein bisschen
die die katze in den schwanz nicht denn
auf der einen seite wollen wir den strom
liga machen weil wir elektrifizieren
wollen aber das steht ja doch sehr in
den sternen und bei den anderen
energieträgern den fossilen die wehr
setzen darum ist teurer machen eben zb
über den co2 preis und da ist jetzt ja
wieder so ein hasenfuß bei der planung
denn wir brauchen ja angeblich jetzt
neue fossile energieträger erdgas also
statt weniger erdgas verbrauchen wollen
jetzt neue gaskraftwerke die ja mit co2
preisen belegt worden sind und die
versorgungssicherheit jedenfalls zunehme
autarkie auch nicht gerade wenn man sich
überlegt wo das erdgas herkommen ich
vordringlich aus russland also da gibt
es doch sehr sehr sehr viele unklare
stellschrauben an denen dann auch der
mittelstand und die wirtschaft insgesamt
leiden werden weil dass er das noch
recht unsicher ist er jack und beim
thema gas hat die haben die grünen eine
ganz andere position als die spd was
gazprom zum beispiel betrifft ist auch
ein punkt wo sie sich da nicht einig
sind und ist dass so ein verein nicht so
ein hasenfuß mit den gaskraftwerken wo
sie auch sagen ja das ist eigentlich
nicht so viel sein sollte oder wie das
große wünschen würden so dass wir kein
freund von austrian zwei waren und sind
dass es bekannt und wir fühlen uns da
auch bestätigt in der diskussion mit
russland das das nicht schlau ist sich
zusätzlich abhängig zu machen von
russland auf der anderen seite haben wir
seit zur webseiten gasimporte aus
russland und werden so lange brauchen so
lange wenn ich die energiewende
verwirklicht haben das heißt je mehr
erneuerbare energien wir ausbauen je
schneller wir werden desto weniger gas
in der perspektive aber jetzt für den
übergang kohleausstieg ist halt
vorrangig für uns atomausstieg passiert
dieses jahr werden wir gas kraftwerke
brauchen die werden flexible gras dann
beisteuern wenn zum beispiel einem tag
wie heute vielleicht die sonne nicht so
gut scheint und der wind auch vielleicht
gar nicht so stark unterwegs ist das
sind dann flexibilität steuerung wir
wollen aber keinen einstieg in einen
neuen gasmarkt im gegenteil wir wollen
einfach nur das backup für die
erneuerbaren energien haben dafür werden
wir es brauchen und in der perspektive
wird es dann grünes gas sein das wird
aber noch ein paar jahre dauern bis wir
in wasserstoff so weit sind dass wir
sagen können wir können die komplette
gasmenge dann auch ersetzen mit
erneuerbaren das nur als kurzen exkurs
weil ihre kollegen aus finnland die
grünen die haben gesagt die seen
inzwischen die vorteile von atomkraft
und sagen das ist eigentlich doch
nachhaltig und man muss das mal in der
gesamtbilanz ziel sehen sie die
diskussion bei sich auch oder ist es
völlig abhängig die gibt es bei uns
nicht ich respektiere dass es
unterschiedliche meinungen in
europäischen union gibt ich glaube das
steht einem dann auch an zu sagen das
muss man dann auch respektieren wir
können ja nicht europa immunologen wenn
wir einer meinung sind und in dem fall
sind wir nicht einer meinung denn hagen
sie wollten auch was zu sagen oder also
ich hab ich hab mal meine diplomarbeit
über atommüll politik geschrieben im
jahr 1990 damals hatten wir kein
endlager und wir haben immer gesagt das
ist wie so eine 747 die man starten
lässt ohne der landebahn zu haben jetzt
haben wir immer noch kein endlager und
vor drei jahren haben wir den atommüll
aus der aus der verwahrung der firmen
wieder in die verwahrung des staates
genommen und wissen sie warum weil wir
die firmen darauf aufpassen müssten für
die nächsten 20 tausend jahre dann
müsste denen ihr wirtschaftsprüfer
gleich sagen ihr seid finanzielle
bankrott wenn ihr für 20.000 jahre auf
den atommüll aufpassen müssen und
deswegen ist das wieder staatliche
aufgabe deswegen werden und wir als
steuerzahler das zahlen müssen und wenn
irgendjemand meint dass man mit atommüll
eine lösung da produzieren kann dann
soll der den atom soll da doch bitte auf
den atommüll aufpassen da kann man den
finnen nach wenigsten vorwerfen die hat
ja sogar so was genau wir wollen das sie
gar nicht mehr träumen kraft diskussion
auf machen aber ich war dass die
positionen sind klar es ist nur
interessant dass es da schon irgendwie
eine bewegung gibt und auch natürlich in
der eu jetzt eine andere entscheidung
frau klöckner sie haben heute gesagt die
grüne warnt auch ich dazu sagen okay
dann machen sie auch noch
ja vielleicht noch einen satz dazu ich
meine wir müssen uns ohnehin um ein
atommüll-endlager kümmern und übrigen
sind die grünen da ja auch
dankenswerterweise ganz vorne mit dabei
damit genau das problem der des alten
atommülls geklärt wird wir brauchen
sichere lagerstätten übrigens ist das
auch eine vorschrift der berühmten der
eu taxonomie wie jetzt hat die atomkraft
mit als nachhaltig
vorschläge zu behandeln das ist geklärt
sein muss wo der dreck hin soll aber das
ist ja nicht so dass wir jetzt aus der
atomkraft aussteigen oder sie nicht
weiter betreiben dass wir dann kein
atommüll lager brauche ich die wir
bräuchten 1 derzeit wird das zeug
oberirdisch gelagert das muss man sich
klar machen und
in der zukunft werde jetzt noch nicht
diskussion wert was du nicht sinnvoll
wäre die atomkraftwerke doch weiter
laufen zu lassen um den klimaschutz zu
bewerkstelligen wenn man doch am ende
ohnehin sich um den atommüll kümmern
müssen und ehrlich gesagt manchmal das
anschaut in gorleben wieviel castoren
das sind ich glaube der gesamten
atommüll zusammenhang etwa das volumen
des brandenburger tors das ist jetzt
also nicht so unendlich schwierig zu
verklappen wenn man denn eine
lagerstätte hätte aber wir brauchen wir
nicht frage glauben sie dass diese
diskussion wieder aufgemacht wird auch
von der union die ja eigentlich auch
gesagt hat das ist abgeräumt oder das
einer der wissenschaftliche die
wissenschaftliche herangehensweise
nachdem von welcher perspektive ich
komme also wenn ich vom co2 ausstoß
kommen oder wenn ich vom endlager komme
aber wir beide sind in der politischen
diskussion und ich bin so viel
realitätssinn und ich erinnere mich noch
sehr gut wie angela merkel wie die
damalige regierung ich war nicht
regierungsmitglied entschieden hat
wirklich den ausstieg zu beschleunigen
und das war übrigens auch mit einer
ethikkommission das war ein ganz langer
prozess und das hat auch etwas damit zu
tun ob wir gesellschaftliche befriedung
auch hinbekommen und ich glaube kaum
wenn wir diese diskussion jetzt wieder
aufmachen dass wir hier dazu beitragen
dass wir uns auf das konzentrieren was
notwendig ist
ich warne davor jetzt von einem extrem
ins andere zu fallen und deshalb sie
hatten sie ja eben schon so an getextet
cup stichwort grüne planwirtschaft das
meine ich damit meine sozialistische
planwirtschaft oder sonst hast mir geht
es um realität sind mir geht es um um
augenmaß und das heißt für mich in der
tat dass wir bei allem was wir schön
malen in den himmel was in der zukunft
ist da kann man sich immer hinten dran
versammeln es geht genau darum jetzt ich
kann es in berlin nicht planen auf einem
blatt papier wie es in ganz deutschland
wo jedes windrad stehen wird sondern
je nach demnach nach lage entscheiden
dass ihre tochter gabriele klug werde
ich bin euer monat politiker ich bin
seit vielen jahren im kreistag und ich
kann ihnen sagen irgendwann haben die
leute vor ort überhaupt keine lust mehr
sich ehrenamtliche noch zu engagieren
wenn alles von oben für ihre heimat vor
ort bestimmt er aber das hat doch noch
in eine angekündigt zu sagen er will
sozusagen sehr stark die leute kann sich
nicht mit 80 millionen reden aber die
leute mitzunehmen sehr stark diesen er
hat er hatte gesagt man muss auch mal
über den eigenen betroffenheit schatten
springen sonst wird es nicht zu werden
und die summe der individuellen
betroffenheiten die verhindert dass gar
nicht wehren volkswirtschaft unsere
vorherige häufig alles super jeden satz
unterstreiche ich aber jetzt gehen wir
mal von der flughöhe ein bisschen runter
in die realität was vor ort geschieht
was wirklich zur zeit in den dörfern
auch los ist und jetzt nicht bezogen auf
in trader hat man an der einen oder
anderen stelle da kann man auch die
parteien gar nicht mehr zuordnen will
ich auch sehr klar sagen aber wir haben
doch in unserer gesellschaft gerade eine
entwicklung auch durch digitale medien
auch dadurch dass wir zum teil auch
verlernt haben zu diskutieren und mit
argumenten ich finde das gut heute am
übergang in irgendwelchen schubladen
hocken aber ist doch mittlerweile fast
nur noch ins gesinnungs debatten bist du
dafür oder dagegen
und das ist ein problem und deshalb
finde ich schon ist das wird nicht so
einfach sein wie man sich dass das habe
ich mit planwirtschaft gemeint also wir
können uns gerne hier einen plan machen
aber das verordnen wird wird kann genau
das gegenteil ich glaube diese
ambitionen die wir formulieren die trägt
natürlich die möglichkeit des scheiterns
in sich das ist völlig klar und sind
deswegen ja auch bemüht und die
gespräche und der erste antriebs besuch
von robert habeck wird ja jetzt nicht in
usa seien beim wirtschaftsminister
sondern bei markus söder sozusagen weil
er mit ihm sprechen möchte wie bayern
sich das vorstellt die zwei prozent sind
freche auszunutzen und ich glaube das
zeigt ja dass er da wirklich die mühe
der ebene nicht scheut und wir sind da
übrigens
das
gespräch und das ist das entscheidende
das reden allein hilft nicht man muss ja
dann mal irgendwo weiterkommen an der
saison gewählt und zu entscheiden wen er
muss klar sagen ja damit aber leben kann
es werde auch eine entscheidung
natürlich
wie sehr oder welche prognose haben sie
da auch aus bayerischer perspektive die
sie kennen entdecken ich habe ja immer
so verstanden dass er dann entscheidet
wenn er das gefühl hat die mehrheiten
sind auf seiner seite und ich glaube
dass die mehrheit in bayern nicht auf
seiner seite sind wenn er die
erneuerbare energie wende zum erliegen
bringt in bayern deswegen setze ich
darauf die überzeugungskraft aber sicher
bin ich mir nicht und wenn er sich
anders entscheidet dann müssen wir
überlegen was für maßnahmen möglich
werden aber wir werden vor ort schon
erwähnten als des landes recht weit ist
was das thema ist die fotovoltaik
ungelenk in blogs wird jetzt war jetzt
nicht so da hinstellen als seien sie
hinterm mond sondern bayern geht da
wirklich ambitioniert auch voran ja aber
ich kann ihnen sagen dass bei der
windenergie genauso 4 gebaut worden sind
ich weiß das weil drei von denen der
kreistag meiner frau gebaut
auch mehr gehen
wie sehr wird diese die ganze debatte
der der frage was man leuten zumuten
kann die individuelle betroffenheit
was was kann es dann noch erwarten und
wie sehr in der zeit wo debatten sowieso
so aufgeheizt sind in dieser corona zeit
also wo was wäre jetzt politisch klug
ihrer meinung nach
ja ich bin den ansatz des ministers
schon richtig gesagt ich sollte nannte
das von integrativ er versucht ja
wirklich die leute mitzunehmen auch die
opposition einzuladen weil das wirklich
man muss es sagen es ist eine
herkulesaufgabe für ihn und die
vorgänger koalition hat dinge
beschlossen die er jetzt umsetzen muss
zugelassenen beschleunigt umsetzen muss
wie zum beispiel anteil der erneuerbaren
energien an oder lang aber die großen
ziele sind ja sozusagen das ergebnis
einer riesen großen koalition nämlich
treibhausgasen bis 20.45 zu werden und
bietet wie man da jetzt hin kommt das
sind das sind die fragen und die möchte
er in den ländern klären er lädt die
länder eint die opposition ein erlebt
die bevölkerung ein das ist sicherlich
der richtige weg aber er muss sich da
glaube ich sehr sehr warm anziehen und
ich hoffe dass er in so zu sagen da
genügend kleidung trägt um das
auszuhalten denn dass das wird natürlich
sehr sehr sehr sehr schwierig ja und das
internet in der zeitung wir wo wir zum
beispiel erklären in der zeit wo wir
wichtige landtagswahlen haben wie sehr
man könnte fast sagen ist es fast naiv
dass der minister oder ist sie wäre die
frage ist es naiv dass er denkt dass
dann auch von den oppositionsparteien
alle an diesem großen ziel arbeiten
naja wenn er das ist ein politiker nach
altem schrot und korn ist würde sich
hinstellen und sagen hier stehe ich ich
kann nicht anders churchill hat gesagt
er hat nach dem tor von barth platz zwei
und wenn ihr das wollt unterstützt licht
dann wählt mich und wenn nicht dann ist
mein platz auch vielleicht oder eine
regierung zu ende und er hat ja durchaus
heute auch gesagt das ist nichts was man
in vier jahren schaffen kann auch das
ist richtig also wenn es diese
riesengroße koalition gibt und die gibt
es denn eine richtige opposition dazu
sehe ich nicht dann muss diese riesen
große koalition auch über diese können
über ihre grenzen springen und
zusammenarbeiten um das durchzusetzen
und da meine ich jetzt auch wirklich
durchzusetzen und nicht dann wieder die
planungs beschleunigen ich das sagen
darf bürgerbeteiligung also oder die
liebe bitte ich würde mir einen
wettbewerb des positiven wünschen um die
energiewende um die besten konzepte ich
glaube auch nicht dass die union eine
position einnehmen wird in den nächsten
jahren das hoffe ich zumindest die jetzt
auf die bremse tritt bei der
energiewende sondern dass wir eben dahin
kommen wer hat die besten ideen den
besten weg diese ziele zu verwirklichen
wir dahin kommen mit den ländern
gemeinsam und ministerpräsidenten sagen
wir wollen dafür gewählt werden dass wir
vorreiter sind dann haben wir viel
gewonnen diesen ja der wettbewerb also
soll sie jetzt ansprechen um die besten
konzepte bin ich bei ihnen aber das gilt
für mich dann auch weil zum beispiel
einer technologieoffenheit am ende wird
sicher etwas durchsetzen was
dem verbraucher oder dem abnehmer
entspricht weist wirtschaft oder auch
verbraucher was bezahlbar ist was zu
meinem komfort passt deshalb haben wir
auf dem gerät wie sie zu den ladesäulen
aus muss schneller den auto schneller
geladen werden können wie sie es in den
ländlichen räumen aus also da gehört da
bin ich dafür absolut ein wettbewerb der
ideen heißt auch freiraum schaffen
heisst zum teil auch weniger regulierung
heißt auch ermöglichung und ist die
köpfe wirklich loslegen können also auch
technologieoffenheit ja hertha nagen sie
wollten dann auch was zu sagen ja also
ich habe ja eben schon mal gesagt
ländlichen raum jedem bauern denen sie
einen glauben der ladesäule an seinen
kuhstall zu bauen der dann soll er freut
sich darüber dass er das verkaufen kann
aber jetzt mal es gibt natürlich andere
probleme die sind wirklich also da gibt
es noch keine guten lösungen das ist zum
beispiel wie machen wir das eigentlich
im wohnungsbereich also wenn sie und da
haben die städte wieder die haben die
schätzer nämlich tatsächlich die
schlechten karten sie können in
großstädten nicht wärmepumpen einfach so
durch den garten legen was sie in
ländlichen räumen was ihnen dort der
dorf an durchaus machen können wo sie im
grunde eine lösung haben sie haben
solardach oben drauf haben die wärme
punkte die sie durch den garten ziehen
und damit können sie mit mit hoher
sicherheit tatsächlich ökologisch heizen
dass das können sie in einer
mietskaserne in berlin neukölln nicht
einfach so machen da fehlen noch die
lösung und da ist bin ich auch sehr
gespannt da sind nämlich hat nämlich ihm
aufgrund noch keine lösung da steht dann
was schönes in diesem habig papier in
den 36 seiten drin es gibt nämlich noch
eine gruppe von leuten die das problem
haben wenn sie so ein haus haben und sie
sind schon 70 und sie ist sollen jetzt
sozusagen eine ökologische heizung ein
oder 75 grad und sie kriegen nur
schweren kredit und sie können überhaupt
nicht sehen wie sie die 50.000 euro oder
100.000 euro oder noch mehr noch es dann
einfach aufbringen könnten ob sie diesen
kritik bekommen da sind lösungen
erforderlich und da sind glaube ich auch
lösungen von allen parteien dieser ganz
großen koalition wie der kollege das
eben gesagte sehr und es hängt dann auch
wieder immer auch am geld frau klöckner
wie fast denken sie wie viel geld muss
man da an die hand nehmen wie sehr muss
man auch einzelpersonen
unterstützen man hat ja
heizkostenzuschuss all diese dinge
darüber wird ja gesprochen was denken
sie da wie sollte man da agieren also
wenn ich jetzt eine zahl sagen würde
wäre das einfach nur gegriffen also das
wäre unseriös ihnen jetzt eine zahl zu
nennen das ist ja ist es vor allem eine
frage des geldes oder mehr eine frage
der organisation
naja die organisation kann sich aufs
geld aus werten also das hat ja was
miteinander zu tun natürlich hat für den
privathaushalt für ein kleines
portemonnaie hat natürlich eine
steigerung der energiekosten eine ganz
andere auswirkungen wie für den rolls
royce portemonnaie das ist jetzt eine
binse es war eine frage aber am ende
gehört für mich mittags wenn es ganz
konkret sagen darf das thema kalte
progression
wir haben in den cdu-geführten
bundesregierung wir haben diese lücke
seit 2016 geschlossen und wenn wir uns
jetzt mal die inflationsrate anschauen
wir sind bei über 3 prozent im
durchschnitt im vergangenen jahr und die
bundesregierung die neue setzt man etwa
zwei prozent an also das heißt dass auch
gehaltssteigerungen wieder aufgefressen
werden und da kann man viel tun findet
da kann man viel tun das hat mir aber
nicht mehr in dieser runde dass wir dann
noch mal wieder ein thema für eine
nächste diskussion und ich denke auch
dieses thema klima wirtschaft da werden
wir bestimmt jedoch oft drüber
diskutieren vielen dank herr janitschek
keine zettel vor glück noch diskussionen
und vielen dank ihnen liebe
zuschauerinnen und zuschauer fürs
interesse bleiben sie bei phoenix hier
geht es jetzt weiter mit phoenix der tag
mit thomas barth bis dahin tschüss
[Musik]